depuis septembre 2001 la sécurité vous
le savez est devenu une véritable
obsession particulièrement dans le
transport aérien
on ne rigole plus sur les photos de
passeport et quand vous fournissez un
renseignement
vous n'avez pas droit à l'erreur ce soir
le fin mot de l'histoire sur nos fautes
d'inattention
richard achète un billet d'avion sur le
web en inscrivant les renseignements
demandés
il est versé par erreur son nom et son
prénom
problème ce qui est écrit sur le billet
d'avion ne correspond pas à ce qui était
inscrit sur son passeport
richard est perplexe il se demande si sa
méprise lui coûtera très cher
cette différence entre son billet
d'avion et son passeport peut
effectivement occasionné de gros maux de
tête de richards il doit contacter sa
compagnie aérienne et faire corriger
l'erreur tant chez air canada air
transat ou air france
on nous dit que s'ils volent idirect il
n'y a pas de frais pour ce genre de
correction
par contre si le billet comporte une
correspondance avec un autre
transporteur il faut payer 50 dollars si
vous êtes chanceux peut-être plus la
morale de l'histoire
tournez votre doigt cette fois au dessus
du clavier
avant d'écrire votre nom